orderflows Trader 8 is the latest
version of orderflows Trader um for
Ninja Trader 8
and what it is is you know for those of
you that are that are new to order
Trader it's not just a footprint chart
right it's a footprint chart that does
extra analysis of the order flow for you
you know
imagine you know you you you want to
start looking at orderflow but you don't
know what the heck you're looking at and
what I've done over the years you know
is take the forms of analysis that I'm
doing other Traders are doing and put it
into the orderflows uh Trader software
and in this release we've added 17 new
tools as well as updated for the
existing tools so it's basically it's a
Improvement of uh basically 21 new tools
so there's a total of 56 orderflow
analysis tools available to you now one
thing to
note when
using orderflows Trader software you're
not going to use all 56 tools right I
mean you know when you open up any
charting software right and you go to
the studies you know there's hundred and
hundreds of different studies you know
there's adx there's DMI um you know
there Donan channels Etc you don't add
all of those all at once and the same
thing with the tools on order flows
Trader um we I want you understand what
the tool does you know depending on the
market that you're trading the time
frame that you're looking at the chart
type that you're looking at um you know
you're going to want to use specific
tools for those markets you know because
if you're trading say NASDAQ right
you're not going to be looking
necessarily at the exact same um
analysis tools or even maybe some of the
same tools but slightly different
settings that you would if you were
looking at say the bonds right or or
wheat um just simply because you know
there's different market dynamics that
ex exist on NASDAQ that don't exist so
much in you know the bond market so you
know just understand that you know every
Market you know trades slightly
different now 2025 is basically the 10-
year anniversary of the release of
orderflows Trader right I released it
the first version when we're back on or
what was it Ninja Trader 7 back in
2015 and we're already on version eight
so we're regularly updating our software
to take advantage of the order flow you
know a lot has changed in 10 years
in terms
of you know the way the Market's trading
you know 10 years ago S&P were trading
you know around you know below 2,000 now
we're around 6,000 so you know with the
increase in price in the index um you
know volatility has increased right and
so you know you got to take you got to
understand that markets are constantly
evolving and really today what I want to
spend time on is I want to introduce you
to the new new Tools in orderflows
Trader 8 you know the overflows Trader 7
already has uh many tools and you can
see here the existing indicators on the
left and in the
middle and like I said we've updated a
few of the tools we've updated the
extreme Delta threshold the extreme
Delta volume threshold the small min max
Delta and the unfinished auctions but
we've added you know 17 new tools right
we've added uh momentum a Delta
histogram Delta stack Delta surge Delta
stack Delta surge are basically stand
um indicators um extreme bar Delta
extreme bar volume extreme price Delta
extreme price extreme Delta change
threshold extreme Delta change
percentage
threshold extreme price level volume um
imbalance auction is also a um new
indicator um PLC Shadows stopping volume
value area absorption um
we've added a new feature to the latter
content of Point controls Point control
itself Point control control 2 poter
control 3 The Zone drawing um ability
which I I'll show you as well I'm go I'm
going to go through all the new tools
and the updated tools and we've added
lad price volume threshold and lad price
Delta threshold okay so again you know
just going through the you know these
are the ones that are updated yeah I'm
not going to name them again and these
are the the new ones okay
so these These are more of the new ones
we got a lot of new ones I couldn't even
fit them on one page
um remember the markets always evolving
so you should do so should your tools
right your tools if you're still trading
a footprint chart that doesn't have you
know analysis tools on it I mean you
you're really putting a lot of pressure
on yourself as a Trader to try and
understand what is happening in the
market and you know
software is a is is something that can
help you understand what's going on in
the market especially when um you know
if if you're newer to
orderflow and you don't necessarily know
what you're looking at you know that's
the problem that I see with a lot of
traders that are new to orderflow the
reason they give up because they don't
know what they're looking at and that's
why we create the tools to not just
process but also analyze and display the
data efficiently right so providing you
with up to the second information that's
crucial for making you know the timely
decisions as a Trader while standard
footprint charts you know they provide
the data you know they just put it in
simple bad ask form here's your point of
control here's your Delta here's your
cumulative Delta um you know here's an
imbalance you know that's all it does
but you know why not have software
that's going to help you understand what
it is you're looking at so you again I'm
not going to have too much you know
slides but it's best to just uh take a
look at the market right with the
footprint chart Okay so
just uh again you know really quick you
know one of the questions I get is how
difficult is it to to use you know and
you know do you have templates well you
don't really need to use any template or
anything like that and I'm just going to
show you really quick how easy it is to
set it up so what you do right if you're
just going to open up a new chart got to
make sure you have tick uh replay
enabled right so the footprint will plot
historically and click okay so you got
your new ninja Trader black back ground
Candlestick chart right which we're all
familiar with you know when you open up
ninja Trader and you add a chart that's
what you're going to get so to Simply
add the orderflows trader software to it
you just you know after you import it
into ninja Trader you just click on
orderflows
Trader and if it's the first time you're
using it then you'll need to enter your
license token in the license token field
if you're upgrading you do not need to
re-enter your license token it's already
saved to your computer
and you click apply okay and the
footprint is going to come up
now I don't like to use a black
background um you know when I read a
book it's not black paper with white
text it's white paper with black text so
to Simply change it the way to make it
more you know common in the sense of
what we look at when we look at uh you
know reading a paper or reading a book I
just go in I change the font size to a
bigger font that is the axis like the
time and the price um you know you keep
it 16 17 18 let's make it 16 here I do
like to add the date and range just so I
know when I'm scrolling through the
chart then you get down to chart
background okay you just change it from
black to white
okay text text the color of the text
change that to Black okay because it's
sort of this grayish colors you you got
white background you want to have black
text okay Crosshair labels I mean you
can them gray if you
want I just like to keep it transparent
because I don't or I just make it
black inactive price markers to make
that black doesn't I don't really use
those but um the axis which is the line
along the bottom and the side you know
before next to the price and time um I
just like to have that black just
for keep everything the same the
crosshairs if you're going to use the
crosshairs if you have a white
background you're going to need to
change it from slight gray to Black
black or you could have blue whatever
but slight gray on white you can't
really see um now grid lines right if
you want to look you know if you want to
have grid lines on your chart you can um
gray is fine you don't want to make it
black gray is is a nice color but I just
like to keep it transparent that's just
me I know there's some traders that like
to have it just you know it just helps
them identify things price level is a
little bit easier but it's up to you
then you click apply boom there you go
okay okay
simple took me a little bit longer
because I'm talking you through it but
if you're just doing it yourself it
should take you less than 30 seconds
okay so there's my footprint chart with
the default settings now there are
default
sets on the overflows Trader
and the defaults are your starting point
for pretty much every Market okay well
it's going to be your starting point for
every Market actually but for you know
the major markets e
minis currencies bonds know crude oil
gold Etc it's fine to start with okay I
I use these on all um and whatever the
default settings are here it's pretty
much the same as it was on orderflow
trator 7 um but we did enable the Delta
histogram just so you could see the
Delta um on the footprint that's one of
the new tools here so you can see let me
get the crosshairs up
here okay
let just make the crosshairs a little
bit darker so you can see it
[Music]
um two is probably fine but I'll make it
three make it more
solid okay so you can see in the actual
footprint chart there's these little
blue or or
red um areas drawn on the chart if it's
blue it's positive Delta if it's red in
the bar it's negative Delta it's just a
different way to analyze
I um Delta as opposed to using a Delta
footprint chart um you know and then
there are certain things you can see you
know there's going to be areas where
there's very strong Deltas like you can
see right in here it's a little bit of a
profile um these are negative deltas and
then you have some positive Deltas again
you could choose to have it if you want
or or not right all these things are you
could add them or delete
them well I don't say delete them but um
choose not to use it
okay
so what am I doing
here one of the major changes that we've
done is in the global settings okay
we've added momentum strength okay in
the past you didn't have this ability
momentum strength and what that means
is if you're using any of these tools in
here that have a setting for momentum
enable momentum strength
filter then what it's going to do is
it's going to reference the setting here
momentum strength and it's going to only
signal if the conditions for momentum
are met okay so if you're not using um
you know for example here Delta breakout
right momentum strength filter it's not
enabled
but so if it's not enabled it's not
going to use momentum on it but if I was
looking at um
the momentum strength
filter right it would reference the
strength up here so one is the weakest
six is the strongest three is sort of
middle of the road so one is like the
first signs momentum six is the
strongest
momentum that we gauge okay so for
example
uh let's
do we'll enable Delta breakout with the
momentum filter
okay and I'll just have it so you can
see it also have it draw the lines and
again this is Delta breakout with the
momentum filter on and it's it's set
at um it's set at
three okay where are we here Delta
breakout Delta threshold is set to 200
okay so my I got euro currency here so
not sure if this going to be any this
morning maybe earlier I might need to
change that based on the market now I'll
change it
to I'll change it down to a lower number
here
well first I'll show
you was it disabled
okay let me
just get it here okay
so right you see this box around it is
is the Delta breakout Delta breakout
Delta
breakout not any more recent here
there's one
here okay see if there's one a little
bit
earlier yeah here so
with the momentum
tool right the momentum
setting all right so you got bullish one
here a bullish and a bearish one
there Delta breakout all right so what
it's going to do is it's going to look
for Delta breakouts that have some sort
of momentum behind it right again the
momentum is just an average right now
it's just set at three um depending on
the market that you're using or looking
at is going to vary so here right you
got the bullish momentum so it's showing
the signal here you have the bullish
momentum here you don't have the bearish
momentum this there is a Delta breakout
that took place here but you don't have
the Delta breakout signaling because
while you have a Delta breakout it
doesn't have the momentum behind it okay
so you know the whole point of using the
momentum tool is to sort of keep you on
the right side of the market okay that's
the whole reason that um you know we put
it in there and again not
every tool
has it because some tools okay just
really quick
here some tools don't have it because I
want to be able to see what's where it
is right where if I have an align point
of control I don't care that's why
there's no swing filter that's why
there's no momentum filter right if I
got an line point of control I want to
know where it's taking place okay um you
know there's there's a couple others in
here you open Point control well I think
open Point control has it but there's
there's a few other tools in there that
don't reference
the momentum filter and that's just
simply because I want to see it every
time it takes place okay so in case
you're wondering he this this indicator
you know like a line point of
control doesn't have a momentum
strength
filter there must be something wrong no
it's because that that's on purpose
right because I want to be able to see
anytime there's an align point of
control okay so that's momentum strength
that was like sort of the the first big
thing big change Delta histogram right
again a Delta histogram provides a clear
visual representation of the difference
between the buying and selling volume at
each price level okay so you got to
identify areas of um strong buying you
know strong aggressive
trading or aggressive selling Now the
default is set to to 20
okay if you make it bigger
the the Delta histogram nonlinear factor
from 20 you know if you make it
say I don't know
75 okay I'll just show you the
difference
here right it makes it slightly bigger
okay when you're looking at your
footprint chart and if you don't want it
if you get a little confused or blinded
by it you just disable it right just
this one where it says draw price level
Delta histogram just uncheck
that
and you want have the Delta histogram on
your on your footprint
okay
um now accumulation distribution is an
existing tool align point of controls
existing buy and selling tailes existing
Delta breakout Delta
Divergence are all existing
tools now one of the new tools what we
have is the Delta stack okay now the
Delta
stack let me just enable it and you know
what I'm going to do just to make it a
little bit easier for you to see things
I'm just going to disable the Prominent
Point
controls and the value area
I'll enable all the other
stuff okay now Delta stack it you know
um last year last year or no in January
felt like last year I did a present I
did a special training workshop and
Delta stack uh PC shadows and imbalance
auction were were three trade setups
specifically that I talked about um and
now we put them in the order flows
Trader so what a Delta stack
is if you're looking at a Delta
footprint
chart
okay let me just pull up a Delta
footprint chart
here a Delta footprint chart right takes
Delta horizontally at price
and what you're looking for on a Delta
stack is you know basically three or
more
Deltas stacked neatly on top of each
other that are over a certain
threshold
okay
so let me just pull up the Delta stack
again turn off Delta Divergence here
I'm going to make it a little bit easier
to see I just going to go down on
size
now what you can do with Delta stack is
you could adjust you know how
many stacks think of it like a stacked
in Balance okay but it deals with Delta
okay mean you could have two and you can
even have it spread
out in the bar
okay so you can see here it's
showing where there's bullish Delta
stack a bearish Delta stack bearish
Delta stack bearish Delta
stack
um bearish bullish bearish all the way
down here bearish bearish
bearish okay bullish one here bullish
one there um and again you know it's
going to vary you know each Market is
going to be um it's going to
differ based on volume okay because
again not every bar trades the same
amount of volume okay so you see I
lowered it down to 20 the default is 25
and the stack size is three but again
you know you can adjust it to however
you want I just I just lowered the
threshold so it be a little bit easier
for you guys to
see and you could use swing filter
momentum filter okay Now Delta surge
guys are all familiar with the Delta
surge I've talked about this a lot you
know we even got the free indicator on
the website
um so we've added it in here the Delta
Surge and you could actually go in now
and adjust the volume levels of bar one
bar two bar three ABC D and the Delta
difference 50 and 25 normally um okay so
I'll just show you here let's make it uh
let's enable it
normally when people look at
a surge right they're just looking at
you know the min-2 the- 26 the- 72 okay
but there's actually you know the part
that they leave out is the way it
increases right they just look at these
raw increases from min-2 to - 26
-72 but really what you're looking for
is
a in big increase here and a slightly
increment mental increase so I use like
50% and I use 25% cuz sometimes you know
people say Well it went from like minus
2 to minus 4 to minus five you know
that's a Delta surge well technically
but not by definition
um you know not not how I would Define
it so you know just you know here 27 57
217 okay because you know like I said
you know people say well -2 - 33 -
63 that's a
surge but you know the increase isn't uh
isn't right okay so it
it adds that missing piece to it right
on the
surge but now you have it on your
orderflows Trader okay so it's going to
be uh a little bit easier for you to see
you don't need a standalone indicator
for it let me just put this back on a
normal bidas
chart okay so this Delta Surge
and Delta Tales existing one exhaustion
print is another one that's existing
extreme bar Delta this is a new one okay
now there's a
threshold it's up to you to determine
what threshold you want to look for
right again that depends on the market
okay so this is eurocurrency and and you
know most Deltas on here are below you
know 100 okay so 200 should be pretty
strong what it's going to do is it's
going to look
for the bars that have Delta that
exceed 200 right so you can see right
here this bar is minus 543 this bar is
plus
544 okay so the minus 543 nothing really
happened Market didn't follow through
then the next bar strong buying came in
right so you had strong look at that
strong negative Delta minus 543 but it
came right back with very strong
positive Delta of 544 it's only
difference of one in the
Delta and you see what happens Market
you know took off right here's another
nice strong Delta again it's a tool to
highlight things in the order flow and
you know if you think hey you know maybe
I don't need this I could look at the
chart if you're looking at chart after
you know day in day out sometimes you
miss just the little minute things
that's taking place in the market okay
and really that that's what orderflows
Traders designed to help you with um
understand what's taking place in the
market right I mean you know a big bar
like this big strong negative Delta of a
th yeah that's easy to determined but
look he could have had a nice little
trade here over couple bars where it
jumped you know 20
ticks okay just by seeing Oh hey you
know what this one's got a strong Delta
maybe I'm not paying attention to what's
happening in the Delta that's going to
help
you
um okay so the next one is the extreme
bar volume similar thing where is it
here extreme bar volume
now
2500 is the default
and again you know if you're trading e
minis it's you're going to maybe adjust
that if you're trading NASDAQ you're
probably going to adjust it as well um
and what that does right is it
highlights the bars that are the volume
is above that threshold Above This is
6,000 this is
4,000 I know if you know if you had a
smaller level you know maybe
1,000 and again depending on the market
you're trading because again this is
Euro currency like these defaults are
sort of set up for E zero currency but
if you're trading um you know some of
the Agricultural markets you're
definitely going to want to adjust it
right because you know 2500 you're not
going to get very
often in those
markets so it's you know it's a tool
because you know when you're looking at
order flow you're analyzing volume so if
you are looking at you know say a swing
high or a swing low and there's a big
jump in volume know you you want to be
aware of that so that you can pay
attention to what's happening in the
order flow
okay you know here are some big volume
that came in right here
right 2500 that was at 654 this morning
if you go even a little bit earlier I
don't know if there was
anything during the European open take a
look
here no quiet open today
but again it's to alert you to things
happening in the order flow because once
you start adding some of these other
pieces of orderful analysis okay well
look I got a strong you know some of
these other tools I got a strong Delta
change or Delta change percentage and
you put it together with you know volume
um the market could be screaming at you
okay let just move on to the next tool
so that was extreme Barb volume extreme
price Delta okay
now that should be okay here with 200 I
think okay so just enable that so what
this is going to do is it's going to
highlight those areas in the
bar where Delta is over the threshold
again 200 is what's being used here and
you see this Bar's
got again it's horizontal Delta Delta at
Price 426 to 181 243 to
two Okay so again this part got the big
volume it's over the threshold you know
it's got a lot of negative stuff
going you know this bar is probably more
important than than this bar that's also
got a big volume right but if you
because you know when you're looking at
bars and trying to analyze what's taking
place in the orderflow what makes this
bar so much better than this bar well
this one's got the heavier volume and
it's got you know the strong Delta you
know there here there was liquidity in
the market over a certain amount a
certain threshold that got through and
started selling off I don't know if
there was anything earlier
here know there was a bearish one here
then a bullish one came in right here
now you can draw these zones out these
are until tested so obviously the next
bar came in and filled it in but anytime
I see a Zone being drawn out like this
to me that's very uh important
information okay know there's one here
it will also highlighted at the top of
the bar that's why you see at the top of
these
um candles you know here being
highlighted um let's move on to the next
one
extreme is it extreme Delta change
now
extreme oh my extreme bar volume still
on there um so this is Extreme price
Delta though that that red box at top
was um extreme bar volume extreme
Delta change threshold okay so just put
it on here for you real quick we'll talk
about it anything else on to confuse
you okay now this is where it gets a
little interesting
um you see on the bottom here there's
Delta change Delta
change percentage okay
so the default is
750 all
right now what it does is it's measuring
the Delta from this over two bars so 105
to -74 is a Delta change of - 809 that's
why there's a red line here at the
bottom of this bar because if you're
below this red line it's going to be
bearish now the next bar it went from
this red bar here -
704 to plus 139 that's a change of 843
okay so you can see it down here on the
bottom and originally um we were just
going to have it on the bottom but we
decided since we've made some changes to
you know the
max like the the Delta Delta volumes
we've made them in here you know on the
chart where you can draw zones from them
we did the same
thing so if we're above this blue line
that's why it's at the top of the bar
okay because if they were above that
it's bullish why is
because you have a jump in
Delta over these two bars what happened
in the Delta it went from minus
700 to plus 139 that's a that's a swing
of 843 in the Delta and if we're trading
above it that's bullish just says down
here went from- 704 to to sorry- 105 to-
704 that's the change of
89 negative but we don't go below this
line that's why this line is here if
we're trading below it that's where you
want to be short from Trading above it
you want to be long from it here's
another bearish one here
okay if there's any others here take a
look
back all right here's a bullish one
right here he went fromus
543 in bar
one to Bar
two positive
544 so it's
swung 1,000
Delta right because you know when you're
looking normally when you look at Delta
you look at it in the bar right it's
positive or negative and sometimes you
know if you're looking at Max and Min
Delta um you you can glean some
information like you know in this little
green bar here you know it was minus 20
Delta for the Min the max was plus 544
so you know it was you know it swung
from -20 to plus 544 which is good but
over these two bars you had very strong
negative selling backed by very strong
positive buying so if we're going to be
above this bars high it's probably very
bullish right you see the market reacted
Market shot up um one of the other
things that we did though with this
indicator which we don't have with all
the indicators is we have a tool on here
under the
zones zonal drawing part bar Direction
where to place the
Zone opposite direction would be on the
bottom or both I'll show you what both
looks like here
okay so it's going to draw on both the
bottom and the top it just gives you an
extra an extra visual that may help you
know some Traders okay because say
you're short you know that's going to be
an area that you'd want to get out of
right if you were short this red bar
you'd say it I'm just getting short
here that's where your Stop's going to
be right just as if you get long here
that's where your Stop's going to be you
know if you're not already taking profit
and you can see here right this low is
what you're getting short of when the
market started doing what selling
off okay so it's just uh we don't have
it on all the tools just
on this one and the next one the Delta
percentage
change so let's take a look at that here
okay so disabled that now here extreme
Delta change also has the bar Direction
I was just explaining now what this one
does is it looks at the change the
percentage change
okay default is at to 500 um I like 500
I've been you know 500 is enough for
most
Traders um some people were telling me
to use a th but uh I think 500 is is
good enough and what it's going to do is
it's going to measure this reading down
here Delta change percentage so minus
770 is above 500 okay if it's above you
know this one's plus 9,000 percentage
wise right because it went from minus 4
to plus
363 so what it's going to do it's going
to draw out the Zone from the bottom of
the bar
right that's where you going to want to
be short from or long from from the top
of the green candle right you can see
right here right shot up it's
interesting because here you can see it
stopped here but then you got a new one
for me so this high and this High very
strong buying when we get up to these
two levels here and here just as here
you got very strong selling you hit this
level one tick above this other level
okay and again you know you could the
default is
500 um but again you you could I don't
think you need a small level like 250 or
something I I like it very
strong where is it here you know you
could even go a thousand but again you
know depending on the market and the
chart you're looking at you can adjust
it how
how how you want and again you could
also use
the bar direction or opposite direction
would be on the other side of the bar or
both okay you see it's right here it's
at the top and it's at the
bottom let's just you know something
this little innocuous bar here very
small
bar we got this nice little sell off
from
1053 down to you know 93 it's 20 ticks
over three bars why because the Delta
just
jumped from minus two to minus 26 is the
Delta increase I mean you get short here
you have just a stop right above here
you know you're risking what one one two
three four five six seven eight
ticks it's a small risk
okay here if you did that you got St out
but um you know here it's a nice move
here's a nice move down
okay so that's extreme Delta change
threshold
now one of the tools that we've updated
if we already on order FL Trader
7 just get it
here you're already familiar with the
extreme Delta threshold right you'll
you'll notice some of the Delta numbers
are cyan some are magenta now we put it
in here as a tool
okay cuz before when you on order FL
Trader 7 you would adjust
the
um strength of it you know somewhere
down in under the lad content sorry not
under the lad content but under this
part here under the summary
content you still still have the colors
you could adjust there what we've done
is we've taken it and we put it up as an
indicator to tell Trader skate 95% is
strong Delta what that means is the
final Delta is closing within the 95
percentile of the max Delta okay or if
it's negative Delta it's closing within
95% of the negative the Min
Delta
okay so you can see right here bullish
right bullish bearish bullish bearish
bearish because you know a lot of times
Traders saying how how do I use this
right well you're looking for those
pickups you know at a swing low or after
a swing low is made you know if if you
know Market's selling off here okay and
you we make a new low down here right
this was your previous low you make a
new low all of a sudden you got two bars
with
strong Delta coming in you know Delta
relative to its what's taking place in
the bar right with the max
Delta 94 it's closing on it's Max Delta
of 94 124 it's closing near its Delta of
129 now it's not coming in exactly at
the low as you'd like but the low was
just made right here now you got the
aggressive buying coming
in what do you think you do you probably
want to get long was your stop just
below this swing
low okay same thing would be you know if
you're at a you know swing High boom you
hit a new swing high up
here and you got a strong Delta coming
in here- 108 you know on the bar after
that swing High you know is it worth a
shot yeah you could scalp that right
there okay so that's uh one of the
updates and then you know the next one
is is similar one it's the Delta volume
threshold which is that number towards
you know the third from the bottom here
which is the Delta divided by um volume
right Delta divided by volume and
you know the threshold that I like to
use is 25 as a
default and you can adjust it to
whatever level you
want you know 25 you know bearish
bullish bullish bullish that's this
number down here 49 25 40 25
35 you know 28 it's
bullish then bullish on a red bar that's
why it's not showing up as a as a
signal but bullish bullish bullish
bullish right here okay bullish ones
down in
here so we've taken how you would look
at this Delta down here at the
bottom and we've helped you put it into
your actual footprint to give you
signals based off of this information
down here all say this is data right and
again you know sometimes if you're
staring at charts you might not pick up
on it right
away let's uh move on to the next one um
okay extreme price level volume okay
default is
200 let's just enable that
here so what it does what this one does
is it calculates the volume on both
sides of the bar at price so you see
right up here this is bearish cuz 137
256 it's over a certain amount right
over 200 which is the threshold that I'm
using just as here bullish bullish
bullish it's kind of
similar
to one of the other indicators from
ninja from our uh water flow trater
7 which is
uh where was it here what is resting
liquidity in a sense but resting
liquidity only looked at one side of the
market where is it here resting
liquidity um this looks at both sides of
the market it's just going to alert you
to hey you know what there's heavy
volume heavier than normal volume going
through now again it depends on the
market you're trading if e minis every
price level is going to be above that
level pretty much but in Euro currency
you know you want to see where that
heavy volume is coming in in the these
bars right and is it getting through and
staying through it or is it getting
through and rejecting the heavier
volumes at those levels because you know
if the Market's rejecting heavier
volume it's going to go the opposite
direction CU
volume in in a way is acceptance and if
you don't have acceptance what do you
got you've got
rejection now the next one
the next new
tool let get it up here is uh imbalance
auction so I just disable the extreme
price level and one last thing about
extreme price level volume like I said
every Market it's going to be slightly
different um but 200 is good starting
point for most markets obviously if
you're in a market that's much more
liquid than
you know you're not going to use 200 if
again if you're trading 10
years you can't use 200 you're going to
use you know
maybe couple thousand um is it's just
going to vary now imbalance auction this
was a this is a
standalone indicator in a sense but I I
taught this one in the workshop that I
did in January of this year
whoops
go right and you're going to
see the zones drawn out here bearish if
we're below it bullish if we're above it
okay we got one from way earlier
here okay so you got this auction this
basically you got this imbalance taking
place at the top of this
bar markets come off a little bit then
you're going through it if you're going
through it you want to be staying long
so basically what you're looking for is
the market to come back through it here
you got the selling and balance at the
bottom of this bar Market bounced up but
we can't get through
it but if we got through it you'd want
to be
short right just as you know over
here right here we got through
it immediately sold off eventually we
came back then you got a bullish one 12
right here buying and balance at top of
this
bar and you see it's just sort of
where's the market yeah we're a little
bit higher right
now not much but we're still higher okay
so that's what
the imbalance auction is right that's a
new tool it's when there's an imbalance
at the auction at the bar Edge that the
market retreated it
from but then comes back and tests it
right two things are going to happen
when you test it right we found that
it's it's a little Nuance in the order
flow CU very rarely you get you know an
imbalance like that at the edge of a bar
because what you have is you know
potentially you got trap Traders right
people were selling or you know in this
case in this red bar they were selling
down into this low Market backed up but
if the selling reappears and starts
getting through it you want to be short
just as if the buying that was here
earlier
reappears you want to be getting long
okay uh let's go take a look at some of
the other ones uh I think we can get to
one till PC so that is imbalance
auction imbalance reloads existing tool
imbalance reversal inverse volume
imbalance Market sweep detector and
again you can see all these we've added
the momentum strength filter here we got
it on the bottom U momentum strength
filter imbalance reload doesn't have it
because I want to see anytime there's an
imbalance
reload Market weakness detector has it
open point of control gaps sequencing
ratio price action Divergence now PLC
Shadow is a new indicator all right this
is a simple one so I'll enable it and
you'll notice it does have swing filter
already default enabled okay there's a
reason for that because it's really
meant to be a moment U not momentum a
reversal
tool okay
and see right up
here PLC Shadow depends on where the PLC
comes in in the
bar
bearish bearish one right here right at
the swing High big swing High here
another bearish one
here another bearish one here
bearish bearish bearish I there any
bullish today um there's a bullish one
small bullish one
here small bullish one
there look at that from this swing High
to the swing
low it's where the POC comes in the bar
okay that's what matters the
most and we call PC Shadows cuz it's a
nice uh kind of think of it like uh PC
in the wick or something I guess you
could describe it as
that but it's it's it's a great uh it's
a great tool the reason why we have the
swing filter automatically enabled is
because again it's meant to be a
reversal tool let go
back this this morning yesterday morning
but you see here yes a nice bearish
signal right there
I mean that's a you know another bearish
signal right there I mean you could just
almost trade these
signals by itself um you know we could
have put it in an indicator and charged
a couple hundred dollars for it but why
just put it in the tool in the actual
order flows Trader
and that you take advantage of it
because when you see poc in the wick
with some other surrounding you know
evidence of what's taking place in the
order flow it could really help you set
you up for a big
trade right I mean you got a reversal
sign here okay imagine this Market was
going up popped up reversal sign then
you can just see the Delta nothing much
but then what you're seeing in this bar
right here very negative bar obviously
the Delta but you got the Delta change
the Delta change percentage um the
volume the bar is over a certain level
the Delta itself is over level even
within the bar itself You' got very
strong negative Deltas taking place
so it's it's it's quite a useful um
little indicator for you I mean you can
almost trade that by yourself by itself
rather
um more so than than anything else um
let's moveing right along
here getting towards the end so let me
see that was PC Shadows but yeah if you
want you can look for them
in bars with momentum but we do have it
enabled for swing filter
automatically um PLC per opponent
controls PLC wave slingshot these are
existing indicators resting liquidity
retail suck small min
max is one you know it's on the bottom
here it would highlight the small mins
or small Max
Deltas but now what we've done is we've
put it actually in here you know in the
top so to speak
to alert you when there are bars with
small min max right and by having a Zone
drawn out it it again these are all
tools basically you know these are all
tools to help you
understand what's taking place in the
order flow
okay by itself you know is one thing
what you want to put it together with
other things that's happening in the
order flow if you were to go I'll just
show you this
uh small Moon Max
here okay you use a swing
filter okay
yeah that is a bullish one at a swing
low but you saw that one
right here at this swing high is a
bearish
one you know another bearish one another
bullish one um depending on how you use
them right you can use them at swing
highs or swing lows now small min max is
something that I like to use in
conjunction with other tools um such as
you know the
Delta um you know bars that have strong
Delta directional Delta or even volume
or Delta
volume not as a standalone it's more of
a compliment
tool but hey you know anytime you
see a bar that has a small min max Delta
you do want to be paying attention to it
okay um let's see what else we got here
stopping volume is going to be the next
one I see a lot of questions coming in I
I'll get to the at the end I don't want
to go through all the questions and just
sort of get sidetracked but uh you know
if you got a question put it in there
I'm not ignoring you I'm just trying to
get through everything here that was I'm
trying to get through because if I start
taking a look at questions
um presentation is tend to get
sidetracked like this so stacked in
balance is existing to a stopping volume
okay it's another one that's a new tool
it's a new indicator basically
stopping volume strength in percent
30% so you're going to have bullish
right
here bullish or bearish um you know you
could use them at swing highs using a
swing
filter now you know one thing to
recognize when you're using anything
volume
related in periods of thin volume you
know or lighter than normal volume
lunchtime
you'll get signals but you know say
you're trading the Asian session okay
you're going to see just go back here
right looks like every other bar has got
a signal it's because the volume is is
very light and if you're trying to
measure stopping volume um you you
probably want to adjust your measurement
you can see down here the percentag is
34 30 77 you know 37 71 but it's coming
out 74 contracts it's coming on 91
contracts
so you may want to sort of take you know
understand that when you're dealing with
volume if say you're on a
volume I don't know it's going to look
like here with
the you know this is a 500 volume chart
okay so maybe volume is going to matter
a bit more so here's
bearish stopping volume there's bullish
stopping volume right bearish bearish
bearish
okay so you just got to understand that
with
whoops with stopping volume right when
you're looking at volume
um so of got to take that into account
now the next
one I want to talk about
is thin prints is existing value are is
existing but what we've done is we've
added a new tool on here it's called
value absorption so you know similar to
a point of control every bar has
a you know a value area right or volume
trades value areas were 70% of the
volume trades whereas point of control
is just where the most volume traded at
a price in the bar but what we've been
able to identify is there are certain
point of controls or sorry value areas
where it's sort of indicative of
absorption taking place so
here first I'll just show you your
normal value areas right if the there's
green and there's red right green if
it's a green candle red if it's a red
candle the value
areas but what we've found is looking at
Value areas
specifically there are some value areas
that do have signs of absorption taking
place
so what you do is you enable value
absorption okay so now what do I
see bullish
absorption bearish absor I call it
absorption it's really distribution
bearish
bearish you know some bullish taking
place here so it's coloring
the value area where this pinkish color
color or this bluish color again these
are all just short sort of shades of red
so here you got bullish bullish
bullish you know the bearish the bearish
the bearish bearish bearish bearish here
but these are not traded into that's why
these zones are being drawn
out okay
so let's take a look here at some of
these other tools real
quick so let's value area
absorption
uh again you know there's a lot of tools
on here the point is not to just go add
every single thing to your chart it's
pointless because you'll get analysis
paralysis it's to add the pieces that
make sense to you you don't I do weekly
training sessions for users where I go
over specific scenarios what you'll be
using how to use the tools in different
markets in case you get lost now um
value area so engulfing value area
vertical liquidity is the same volume
decline is existing tools volume and
balance zero print now unfinished
auction I've changed this um a bit to
make it more usable I didn't like the
way it was before
we just call unfinished business uh
change the name actually to unfinished
auction but now what it's going to do is
you can you could use it in swing filter
so it's just going to draw
out you know the
level it's going to put it at the bottom
of the red candle top of the green
candle
um you know in in a falling Market
generally you're going to see unfinished
auctions right that's kind of what you
like to see in a falling Market in a
rising market you tend to like to see
unfinished auctions on the upside okay
so if I have one that's being drawn out
like a Zone like this where the market
comes
off has unfinished auction comes off I'm
always going to watch when it comes back
because normally when it comes back it's
going to stall there you see it stalls
here in the past how a lot of Traders
used to trade this is they got an
unfinished auction they just leave an
offer up here
right because they're looking for this
Market to come back the reason it's
drawing it green color is because if you
get to the other side park it's probably
going to keep
going but this is an area to get short
from right to scalp just like here it's
one tick through then comes
off here it hits this level pulls back
we're coming off really when you're
looking at unfinish
auctions you know you want to get to
those levels where you know they they
been held for a while as a buying
opportunity
here you know or potential selling
opportunity here um again I'm not a big
fan necessarily of Unfinished auctions
but I wanted to make it more usable uh
for Traders than the way we had it
existing before
okay um anyway we're getting towards the
end of the the tools which is good um so
I can take a look at your questions
bear with me
here uh let's see scroll down so that
was unfinished auction where are you
there there we
go ladder content
so you know you can have point of
control okay and again you you see the
point of control in every bar but you
also have point of controls two and
three the second most volume in the bar
and the third most volume in the bar
okay now in the past it was always just
fixed okay but now you can draw it out
until tested right because Point control
is basically it's Market generated
information right this is volume and you
know anytime I have a point of control
the market is running away from it a
virgin point of
control it's an area where you know when
you have you got bearish here bearish
here bearish here you know that market
will often come back and
come back to those areas and and trade
through it right it doesn't necessarily
leave a lot of version point of controls
okay but now that's just the main point
of control you could also do the second
and third point of control now you're
going to probably want to change the
colors you don't want to keep it uh well
here I got much transparent but you
know maybe make the second one
blue third
one you know whatever color I don't know
Crimson which is like a
red okay but that's fixed all right so
you can see the second and third we you
always do that but now you can draw them
out until tested
okay here so you can see you know we got
these sort of these clusters these
volume clusters when the market comes
back to the top of
it there ways to trade this um I'll be
discussing these different ways to trade
these um you know in the weekly
sessions because I've did a whole course
on point controls and strategies using
them so I'm not going to get into that
here today but um there there are ways
you could use Mar controls two and three
uh to help you with your
trading okay now just a couple
more getting through it here so that's
the point of controls so one of the
newer features is being able to draw
them out until tested right because you
always you know profile Traders always
talk about virsion point of
controls on the profile but you know
that I hate to say that Reed you to do
some work and draw them out whereas here
now you don't uh necessarily have to to
do that software does it for
you um okay so last one that I'll talk
about today is this one latter volume
content so we have two things price
volume
threshold and price Delta threshold what
do I still got here oh change
this hang on I I got to drink some water
guys okay so price volume
threshold so if I want to see the times
where price trades over 100 oh that's
200 100 in the
bar
either when if it trades on the ask just
show
me the
the the volumes okay well that's the ask
okay but if you want the bid all right
you also got to do it because see I'll
just show you that right I just enabled
it for the right just for the ask that's
why it's just showing this volume here
at 112 that's the only time you trade it
over 100 but really what you want to do
is you want to do both
sides
the bid side as well as the offer
side
um where am I here
here it
is so it's going to show me CU some
people you know they just say you know I
don't want to see all the bid ask taking
place they just want to see the heavy
volume you know the volume that's over a
certain size in a bar because they have
a way of trading it um you know with
liquidity understanding liquidity it's
just a way to see where there was volume
over a certain size in the bar without
actually out doing it you know there's
workarounds in the past this just makes
it a lot easier for Traders that are
trading that way and lastly we have it
where you could filter
it by the
Delta over the same amount
so take that
off Delta threshold I don't know we have
here but
enable use price Delta
threshold
100 okay so you can see these areas now
it's going to show the volume on both
the bid and the offer so you can see
actually how it traded 108 versus
0 10 versus 111 115 versus 2 because
there are ways to trade Delta in a bar
um I've explained this in the trading
cycle IIA and the Delta trading course
how you can trade that heavy Delta um
numbers like this and this is a way to
filter them out so you can see you know
these guys here has a lot of aggressive
buying here that didn't go further well
there's a lot of aggressive buying
didn't go further the market starts
trading
down what do you think the direction of
the market is it's probably down it say
um you know here heavy B volum it gets
through it okay heavy Deltas gets
through it so it's probably
bullish down here there
was Heavy selling down here 325 then you
got very strong aggressive buying right
the
219 204 here and we're trading above
right so you know that there was strong
aggressive buying taking place down
there so that is the
uh price Delta
threshold okay summary content you again
we've added the two new ones in here
Delta change Delta change in
percentage very useful tools volume
profile is an existing
one existing
tool and these are the plots the up and
down triangles now there are just you
know really quick I didn't want to point
it out you might get down here you'll
see plc one two three value high low
value aborption we have these we cannot
make them this we cannot not have them
here way ninja Trader is being pro don't
there's but there will be no triangle
for volume value are absorption or PC
ones two threes value area highs or lows
those are just in there by
default so that
is the new features of orderflows Trader
8 so if you're an existing user you
should have an email already in your
inbox it was sent out just as this
presentation was starting I didn't want
to send it out before just because I
didn't want
people not attending and and trying to
mess around with the new version and not
understanding what it is um you know
there is one thing to note if you're
upgrading from order flow Trader 7 to 8
you do need to start your chart from
scratch you cannot use your existing
water flows Trader 7even chart because
there are new tools on here that's
trying to access information that
doesn't exist on the orderflows trader
7 charts so you it's going to kick off
some errors in ninja Trader okay so I
showed you at the beginning how easy it
is to set up a chart it should take you
less than 30 seconds people well 30
seconds you know we all got time